um let's go next where are we going next
let's talk to oz from kentucky oz it's
been a while what's going on
hello david can you hear me yes i can
oh lot's been going on i'm so happy that
i was able to get through so
i decided to run for us house of
representatives here as an independent
okay and my
lucky four which i'll be running against
thomas massey that's who my
representative is
and um i've got the signatures required
to get on the ballot and i'll be going
to frankfurt to file this week and i
have a website
which is oz2022.us
which has my bio and platform on it how
many signatures do you need or d i mean
what i mean is i know you got them but
how many signatures did you need to
collect
400 okay i have about 100 i was gonna
try to get a thousand just because the
more the better but i'm just uh running
out of time
because i have some other that i'm
working on that i haven't been able to
focus because i've been trying to get
these and it's been really tough
because i've only been doing it like one
day a week when i'm off work right to go
signatures and it's not
you know i do that a similar you know i
work for a union and i do similar things
for the union and uh
and community organizing but uh
it is dangerous i was assault or had
people try to assault me two different
times while i was out canvassing why
would just collecting signatures made
them want to assault you
uh well the first one happened actually
on christmas eve was when i started the
whole thing of getting signatures and um
the first one was just like a random
crazy like crackhead guy and he was
shirtless and it was probably like 40
degrees out on christmas eve and we were
in front of a church
and and he came up and he started
harassing these elderly people and was
trying to get into the church and then
he started yelling at me and then he ran
up and i happened to have bear spray
like within arm's reach and i blasted
him in the face with it and was
able to repel
yeah
all right well it sounds like a lot is
happening what's i i don't want you to
give me your full platform but what's
your main issue going to be for your
campaign
um well the main issue is
taking control of kentucky's natural
resources and i want to see coal and
everything and water and other natural
resources
socialized or nationalized i prefer the
term socialized because it's a little
different but
people here don't really that's a hot
word buzz i try to avoid buzz words like
that that trigger people and not wanting
to listen but sure and people like
oligarchs like mitch mcconnell control
this the natural resources here for 40
years and they've been pillaging the
state
and the these natural resources belong
to everyone and they should be used to
enrich the the lives of the citizens
not line the pockets of the oligarchs so
that's one thing and you know for
criminal justice reform is at the top of
my list
by myself being in recovery and being
through the system i know how corrupt it
is i want to see
the change to the
systemic problems that we have with our
criminal justice system and um
well those are worthy causes oz those
are two i know we don't have time for
every campaign point are you uh are you
thinking of a slogan i think you could
play off of dr oz
and kind of be like i'm the oz that
won't recommend drinking silver or
something like that that could be cool
i'll say that twitter ain't big enough
for both of us when it comes to dr oz
i'll tell you that
let's logan's get smart kentucky because
kentucky needs to get smart and stop
electing these people that are
oppressing them right wow well oz we
wish you the absolute best of luck keep
us posted on the campaign okay
2022.us please check it out thank you
all right there it is
longtime caller oz is running they said
to him sir will you run
and oz said yes i will so you guys can
check that out let's take a very quick
break we're going to go right back to
the phones after this short break so
don't go anywhere if you're holding on
to talk to me